hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the Machine the amnesia
custom story okay so this thing was
trolling me apparently I go I just
turned it when we left off and it
finally decided to work and now it seems
that there's a monster about which isn't
cool the music either I don't remember
what the music was before it seems a bit
more ominous now okay
this is where it came from ah but the
bone tender box ending under the stairs
nope never a good hiding place though
for when I'm in total fear for my life
Oh like this
it's all this then hmm does airplane I
can't go up into the discipline chair go
down there's a wheelchair go go here go
chair don't don't mess with me what the
hell tear oh it's a diary care okay
check uh chairs in this in this custom
story are behaving strangely hey can I
go in here I can yeah I can totally
maybe maybe whoa maybe not how much oil
I got not enough it was a big one huh
come on oh come on I can see it is ah
man mmm yeah man come on here's been
cares bit okay I try just one more thing
and then I'm gonna give up cuz I did
complete the thing that I was gonna do
do the thing nope uh-huh okay okay so
just go back and do the thing
huh the monster couldn't come bursting
out of there
okay that's down that's up down up this
should be working right did that open
the UM the thingy downstairs ah ah damn
it that again
ah okay oh oh oh ah
ah no yes no yes no okay
I got this yeah I'm you guys creepy
you're bad mannequins you are mannequins
yeah uh-huh
uh-uh
I'm by the light what's out up there
huh huh huh loser huh honey I thought
you were dead
I've seen terrible things and everything
was dark and now I'm here in the cell
then I open hey is anybody out there
could you hear me I'm Alice that hair is
huh huh
yes I laugh a god bless you here maybe
there is a chance to escape from this
doom place yes it's all my fault but
there's no time for explanation we track
quickly there's no time to explain
machines braiding your Bravo heads yes
it's a living machine I didn't hear you
need to find a cage open this damn doors
this damned worse dude your laboratory
and check the menu with a little bit of
luck you'll be able to free your life so
don't waste your time I remember all of
my help
you can get out of here
who said that was that the person in
this cell okay so my lady wife is
supposedly in that one aha see
laboratorium their line that's at the
laboratory I can read I hope this is a
long listen this is a long integer
because this is really good okay I'm
really enjoying myself
I like the idea of a living machine
kinda maybe that's just cuz I'm a nerd
ah Lucas coos goal Lantern Negin oh wow
it's so terrifying
um oh here we saw I saw a saw huh
anything ladder ladder I got a ladder
what if we good Oh up there uh-huh yeah
ha ha good no you shut about oh yeah huh
yeah yeah and then come on no okay
I'll save you ladder for one I there's
something behind the door
oh mama monster I ain't afraid
ain't scared of nothing oh whatever
not scary oh no it's a pile of dead
bodies
we're not scary got my way got my chair
you're haunted ah there we go don't know
why I need sanity potions sanity
recovers anyway right I got a slight
headache Oh xxx sandy potion okay then
there
this that looks like poison gas I don't
see anything useful oh there's some
laudanum ah
that's something in the other corner
other a very brave man
oh okay Maura well thank you God still
really dark hello
nope not today it doesn't look like
there's anything in there anyway okay
what did I come down here for what oh
hello
cool got it I got it thanks to the hint
I could have figured it out whatever
give it yeah ah so slow come on Oh get
that's right
throw it a million miles but I can't
carry a two feet come on get some there
we go yes thank you
can i what good can i well that doesn't
really help me now does it
ah man
alright chair try I need you no chair
you go screw yourself I don't need you
right now ah ah yeah come on and then
there we go
things I have to do what the hell oh
tight fit ah come on there we go
ah let's go oh I don't look good
how can I get through there saw
chugga-chugga yeah that worked
hey rat mouse rat huh ah I can't get me
up here that's the same one from before
I couldn't I get up there hmm
Oh does that body wookie uh-huh dude I'm
the UM the dead body what huh
what yeah Hey all right what what what I
don't get it with that all that and you
whatever got the key
can I get back out or do I have to do I
have to I'm up here
no yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dammit okay
Larry try okay yeah I can move this
why would I there was a monster not big
ol scary monsters
[Applause]
I have to get out ah huh give me the box
ah ah come on don't [ __ ] with nice
ah goddammit
god damn it stop nothing with me what
are you hitting can't hit me okay you
live that box okay please just work huh
hello douchebag how's it going oh come
on I need to climb ah now got ya here we
go okay just stay there
shut up I got sandy Oh finally
God knowing why did I move the boxes
those monster obviously ID I'm not even
a little bit insane damn it
shut up guy you can't find me maybe you
can
I've never really paid attention but
this is really intense music like this
is part of the terror just that this
music is just so damn
murder your soul still down there
I'm the closet
[Applause]
if you're not going to go away
okay
okay come on
[Applause]
come on
oh I get it I got it I got it so smart
not scary and music goes away and give
me some notes that's okay it's you again
you got the key well done now open
distortion get me out of here honey
what are you doing you promised to help
me don't listen to her only I can help
you
it's a trap you need to choose honey
releasing one person
you know what to do choose wisely uh
given that I couldn't hear from where
the voices came from I'll pick this one
ah you don't touch your wife as live
your tyrants was enough No Deal
dad I don't do what you gonna do what
you gonna do now what the hell now I can
see clearly what I have done this idea
with a demon was a mistake
lift me repay for my fault here is the
key to the Zeppelin my last greatest
invention it's located at the upper
levels of mesh levers of machinery just
the first door to the right when
entering the machine from my mansion
search for a green rod which I used as a
kid to the demon circle then take this
rod to the big room with 10 pillars not
far from here and put it inside a hole
which is behind the big barrel big
barrel the passage to the demon circle
shouldn't be opened from the point you
will be on your own find you ageism
demon back to hell
and purify my name yer tears
well that's stupid that's stupid
my wife was she was deed
I went up I went to her she ran across
the street I picked her up she was deed
anyway
if you know what I'm referencing at all
I plot you okay so I need to find a
green rod and stick it in the back of
that big barrel up in the Zeppelin oh no
not that's gonna have to wait I gotta
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye-bye